I love graphics and they tease my eyes
challenge my mind and extend my
understanding and after practice and
design for nearly eight years I'm still
blown away by their power to communicate
see what I've learned in that time is
that graphics are like a form of
language and it takes time to find your
voice for me things really clicked about
the time I created this poster for the
Musashino Theatre Festival in Tokyo you
know my goal for this design was simple
the creative graphic that captured
perhaps the magic our eyes might
experience when we see something amazing
after six years I still enjoy exploring
the color and form of this image it's
become a symbol of my love for graphics
and it was truly fascinating is it for
thousands of years humans have used
graphics in various forms to communicate
abstract ideas you know from the elegant
cave paintings a shovel cave depicting
an array of ancient animals to Buddhist
mandalas depicting the universe to
arabesque patterns that show the
principles of governing our world
graphics is always yelped humans capture
and communicate abstract processes at
work in our minds and in the world
around us now fast-forward hundreds of
years and you'll see that we've been
raised in a Golden Age of graphics and
they surround us sometimes in terrible
ways but occasionally in beautiful ways
and in a digital age they're proving
again to be a powerful communication
tool now in 1945 something amazing
happen
ENIAC or the electronic numerical
integrator and computer was turned on
and this is widely considered to be the
world's first digital computer and this
huge calculator started an armed race to
build the world's fastest tabulation
devices now these machines were out of
this world for the people at that time
and it's unsurprising that companies had
a hard time explaining what they did or
really why they were important you know
a photograph simply couldn't capture
their inner workings so they turned to
graphics designers such as Anton
Stankowski who actually coined the
phrase the visual presentation of
invisible processes in the 1960s were
mission to create abstract
representations of what these machines
could accomplish you know these graphics
captivated the imagination and started
communicating this new and invisible
world happening within computers and
they did it with style so 50 years later
human ingenuity is pushing us even
deeper into these invisible worlds
whereas the 50s and 60s was you know an
exploration of hardware and 60 70s and
80s it was arguably an exploration of
silicon and software the exploration of
our day is data and more importantly the
potential of data and yet again graphics
are proving to be an invaluable tools
helping us describe and share the nature
of the many complex processes within
these invisible worlds you know from my
early days at Wired to my extensive work
with IBM to fooling around with the
folks at Facebook and most recently Visa
I've always been fascinated by the
worlds within our networks and devices
and this fascination has set me on a
journey of drawing the invisible today
I'm often commissioned to create
abstract graphic representations of
things you can't see themes such as
connectivity personalization scalability
to name a few ur are all common threads
in my work
all of which display vast invisible
processes so how do you make a picture
of something you can't see for me I
start by asking questions and creating
puzzles for example these sketches so
some of my first real work with abstract
graphics a little company called IBM
commissioned me to create a series of
visual compositions of contemporary
technical phenomena they want a purely
graphic non representational designs
presenting terms such as insight risk
computing or simply data I mean this was
an amazing yet daunting assignment and
where do you start when you're asked to
create an abstract representation of
data see at my core I'm a visual
storyteller so making pretty pictures
isn't good enough for me
it's important that I really understand
the subject and I create something that
is smart as well as beautiful and this
is why I start by
asking questions I would question
everything about the subject there were
no stupid questions I mean what makes
data data how do you structured data
what's the nature of raw data I would
sit in my studio having these low level
existential conversations that you know
I is an art major in college was
completely unqualified to have but
something constructive would emerge that
would be the seed for an image that
could artfully but intelligently
represent these subjects for example
data is just simply information that's
been collected we all understand that
it's simple you know another thing is
that you know a single piece of data is
useful but generally knowledge happens
by climbing multiple and oftentimes
unrelated pieces of the data that makes
perfect sense but lastly data is always
changing so it's alive and like anything
else that's alive it's subject to
external pressures and hierarchies now
when I go through this exercise this is
where things start getting visual for me
and I start making puzzles let's play us
out a little further a piece of data is
called a data point well in my world
this is what a data point looks like to
me you know but when you add enough data
points patterns begin to emerge and
eventually a picture fills in and then
when you add a sense of depth you
breathe life into the hierarchies and
the pressures governing those patterns
and then what eventually emerges is my
abstract representation of data you see
by asking questions it's how I distill
these subjects into the key attributes
that define them and it's these key
attributes that guide my hand and really
what emerges are graphics that are
evocative of the many complex and
invisible processes at work in
technology today
so you know whether I'm constructing an
image representing the tsunami of DNA
data we're currently collecting now or
how data and analytics is improving our
personal health you know my motivation
is to capture and celebrate the abstract
nature of our existence into beautiful
cognitive puzzles and I've come to
understand that my graphics draw upon
many of the principles of governing the
natural world things like multiplicity
pattern chaos form and function but
perhaps the strongest asked with my work
I think is when I combine geometry with
iconography and a great example of this
is a series of six interlocking posters
I created for IBM's think exhibit in New
York but you know another thing I've
learned over the years and I find
absolutely fascinating is the ability
for these graphics to transcend language
and culture in the work I was doing at
IBM was central to a communication
platform that spanned over a hundred and
thirty countries from China to Chile IBM
was using these designs to talk about
and communicate some of the more elusive
and complicated stories they wanted to
tell so now I'm really excited to share
a piece of work I haven't shown yet
so since working 60 hours a week to seem
you know too easy I started a new studio
a new hybrid storytelling and design
studio called story TK and we recently
concluded a collaboration that combined
many of the graphic disciplines I love
abstract graphics infographics and
motion graphics and the client was visa
and they asked us to tell the story of
visa net the Global Payments network
system that processes over seven
trillion dollars in transactions every
year and this is my biggest challenge
yet something so big and so technical
demanded I get out of the studio and
into the field and my first stop was
visas data center in Virginia after
getting a biometric scan and passing
through an airlock tunnel I was able to
see the guts of one of the world's most
sophisticated and secure global networks
and I got to talk directly with visas
top engineers and was able to ask the
questions that would help me distill
this incredibly complex system into a
simple list of attributes things like
ubiquity security and equality
immediately raised to the surface
and this prompted me to ask one simple
question that would put me on a path to
a solution is each and every transaction
viewed equally in the eyes of the
network so whether you're spending two
hundred thousand dear Amanda buy for a
new Mercedes or $2.00 in Denver for a
pack of gum does visa net treat each of
those transactions equally the answer
was yes you see they were so used to
talking about transactions in the
thousands or millions that had
convoluted a very simple yet beautiful
fact that electronic payments like
snowflakes are actually completely
unique moments in time and I was
fascinated by this and I was obsessed to
find a way to capture this graphically
and working with visas data scientists
we distilled that every transaction has
a key set of variables that give it its
unique signature things like merchant
type amount time from there I developed
a graphical system based on abstract
forms to visualize these variables and
once the design logic was coded the
system would generate unique digital
signatures we began calling snowflakes
so whether you were buying a wedding
ring for your bride-to-be or paying for
your child's college tuition or making a
donation to your favorite charity
this system combined the power of
information and abstract graphics to
capture and visualize the data moving
through one of the world's most secure
and sophisticated global networks and
yet again graphics with a key part in
helping us capture and explain a complex
and mostly invisible process and as
people continue to build ever more
complex and invisible technological
wonders abstract graphics will be even
more necessary to communicate how they
work yet no matter how much I celebrate
abstract graphics is a powerful
communication a storytelling device
their ability to delight its powerful
and undeniably beautiful thank you